[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty and access management or IAM in
Google Cloud gives you fine-grained
control over permissions but it can be
complex to manage the IAM policy
troubleshooter tool can help you
investigate access issues like why a
user or service account has access to a
resource or doesn't have permission to
call an API let's walk through how to
use the policy troubleshooter
we can access the policy troubleshooter
using the Google Cloud console the
command line interface or the rest API
for simple queries using the Google
Cloud console is easy and includes a
visual aid for more complex scenarios
consider the command line or rest API in
this video we'll focus on using the
policy troubleshooter through the cloud
console first off we'll need three
parameters to use the troubleshooter a
principle a resource and a permission
the principal field is where we can
enter the email address of the principal
whose access we want to troubleshoot
this email address can refer to a user
or a service account let's use a user
account with the email user at
tsc.junix.net
the resource field is the full name of
the resource that we want to check
access against the path of the full name
varies depending on the resource type
for example the path for our project is
cloud
resourcemanager.googleapis.com projects
and then the project ID
to see what format to use for full
resource names check the documentation
the permission field is the permission
that we want to check for similar to the
resource field a list of permissions
will be presented as we start to type
let's use
resourcemanager.projects.get which
grants access for a principle to receive
a project
for a complete list of permissions check
the permissions reference documentation
the permission that you need to access a
resource might be displayed as part of a
permission denied error in addition you
can always refer to the specific product
documentation page for a list of roles
and permissions that are required to
access a product's resources
if you want to check additional
permissions for the same principle you
can add multiple resource permission
pairs
let's continue by checking the access to
this project
the top of the page confirms the
evaluation information we're looking for
it's important to note that the policy
troubleshooter only shows policies that
Grant access and that you have
permission to view other policies might
affect this principle such as deny
policies or policies that you don't have
permission to view for more information
reach out to your organization
administrator
in this case the policy troubleshooter
shows that this user should have access
the resources section shows the relevant
resources and the role binding section
shows the roles that contain the
permission you can also choose to show
all bindings including those that don't
include the permission
this user has several roles that Grant
the projects.get permission we can also
see more details about the binding which
shows more information about the role
permission and principle this binding
shows that the role contains the project
stuck get permission and that our
principal has been granted the role
giving them access
if we look at another role we can see
that this role contains the evaluated
permission but the principle does not
have this role
you can read more about the policy
troubleshooter in the documentation and
try it out for yourself in the Google
Cloud console
[Music]